Now that we have a derived feature x, before we go on to making
kernel density estimates let's look at a simple histogram, of this feature x.
Let's switch to our [INAUDIBLE] in this block off code here,
in the [INAUDIBLE] we have defined the variable x.
We're going to bend it between 0 and 1 with 100 bins.
We're not going to normalize it, so we can look at the number of entries.
Let's run this piece of code.
Once the code has finished running,
you will see a histogram that looks like this.
This is our variable of interest x.
It ranges between 0 and 1.
It also has two definite peaks.
One at the value of zero, the other between 0.8 and 1.
Somewhere around 0.89 or 9.
Notice that we had two variables in our model, but
we have changed that to a single variable x,
which is a combination derived from the two variables here.
This will let us use a single variable kernel density estimate,
to build a model of x.
Form the derived variable corresponding to x, for the state of California.
Name it y.
Once you're done click on this box.